I'm in Bengaluru in India and I'm in a
really special lecture theatre and it's
not just special because of this chalk
holder and never seen one like this
before but it's special because this is
the lecture theatre where the very
famous Indian scientists CV Raman used
the lecture and in the Institute which
he built in 1948 my father heard him
lecture in 1930 when he was in the UK
but this is the closest I'll ever get
here in his lecture theatre he was a
famous spectroscopy and a famous
collector of minerals but before we look
in the minerals let me show you
something this is his walking stick
Brady always feels that you get really
close to somebody when you use their
walking stick so it's almost like
holding Romans hand why she does it do
baby roll around oh this fool object
Raman was born in 1888 and he died in
1970 a year after I started doing
research so this institute is still
doing research and there is a museum
here of the things that belong to Raman
and this his stick is one of them CV
Raman is really famous because he won
the Nobel Prize and here and this is the
first time you've ever seen it on our
videos this is what you get when you win
the Nobel Prize and you can see here it
says the name of the swedish royal
academy and here is ramens name and it's
all in Latin or and Swedish so I can't
work out exactly what it says it looks
great and it's all hand-painted because
they make a special one for every Nobel
Prize winner and Raman is particularly
special because he was the first Indian
to win the Nobel Prize and he is still
the only
Indian scientist who's won the Nobel
Prize for doing science here in India he
was also the first person in the whole
of Asia to win a Nobel Prize so this is
the citation and here is you can perhaps
guess is the medal the medal has on one
side the portrait of Nobel and on the
other side has a picture of the
scientist and veiling nature
we've only discovered a small amount
about nature so far so the scientist is
still unveiling her head underneath it
has ramens name engraved quite modestly
and the year of the Nobel Prize which
was 1930 it's a really nice nobel prize
it looks quite worn i think a lot of
people must have handled this but i feel
extremely honored to have been allowed
to hold this and it's something that I
remember for many years raman gave his
last lecture in this theatre on the 2nd
of october 1970 and less than a month
later sadly he died and he was cremated
just outside
let me show you after Amon died in the
Indian tradition he was cremated and he
was cremated here just outside the
Institute that he had built and now the
place where he was cremated has a tree
that was planted on it just after he
died and many years later this area has
become a football field and you can see
the tree is on the centerline of the
football pitch and surprisingly the tree
is actually on the pitch so Raman who
apparently was not very keen on sports
now finds himself on the edge of a
football pitch
so now I'm going to show you ramens
collection of minerals lots of people
had collections of minerals but his is
special because he collected them all
personally